[Music]
what do you want from me
what do you want from me what are you
wondering
what do you know why are you scared
[Applause]
my
[Applause]
i need big shows big ideas hey i have a
big one
with click hello oh you know calloway
clay callaway is a recluse no one's seen
it for 15 years
i'll give you three weeks to get this
show up and running i won't let you
i have dreamt of performing in red shore
city since i was a little kid
there's nothing holding me back this
[Music]
this is my daughter portia she wants to
meet calloway big fan my sister is on
her way to meet him
right now
[Music]
your destination is on the right on the
right okay
if you could just give me some dance
lessons you will be saving my life how
do i know that you're not a weirdo
how do i know that you're legit
[Music]
and here she is the star of our show
rosita oh my gosh can i try
no no no no
she's afraid she'll never be able to
play the part maybe this is for the best
i'll write you another part
there he is clay callaway go away
don't you miss the music you just need
to play again
no i can't i haven't even heard one of
my songs
in over 15 years and for good reason
i have climbed the highest
mountains i have run
through the field it's okay
your songs will carry you
[Music]
dream big dreams that's what i always
said
right
[Music]
there's always a choice just never have
the guts to make the right one
activating piggy power
[Music]
hey you kids it's dinner time
dinner time my favorite nighttime
why does nobody come in through the
front door dearest mother and father
we will not be attending this evening's
ritual mastication
what they're both growing up so fast
they wouldn't be caught
dead with their parents
wait a minute what i've got a dish
it's kitties it's monstrous
it's the old adam's camper
time for some family bonding what huh we
are going
on a road trip this is cruel even for
you
let's roll
this trip will bring the atoms closer
than ever before
let's make some memories
[Music]
my music's so loud
it's just us and the wonderful sound of
[Music]
silence
ah here he is
i still don't understand the word that
guy says
was kitty he and it hit the catnip
pretty hard last night
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
delivery i gave you the special since
you're the only madrigal kid with no
gift
i call it the nut special special since
uh you have no gift uh thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gift or no gift i am just as special as
the rest of my family
who wants more pink all right guys where
do i drop the wagon maybe your gift is
being in denial
[Music]
imagine a device that is the fastest
most advanced
complex piece of technology in the world
but what if it wasn't just a device
what if it was your new best friend hi
introducing
the bee bot it connects you to the world
like never before
express yourself imagine
without limits
create play and enter
a new world of friendship the bebop
let's make friends wow
happy late birthday barney oh dad you
got me one
[Music]
hi insert registered name i am your
your your my bee bot
be bought
there's something wrong with it it's not
meant to do that i'm not meant to do
that
i am for making friends does barney need
friends well yeah or fun fact he will
not survive middle school
[Music]
i am insert registered named best friend
out of my box
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now behold the transformation ray
awesome but is this safe though let's
find out
huh is everything okay down here
hey drac what's up johnny oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
dad you're human drag oh no i have a
total dad bod
um what is going on
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've
literally never seen you before
we need to find a way to fix this there
is a place deep in the amazon
only there can the transformations be
reversed
time to go right
stereo
wow flying as a monster is so much
better right
nervous liar huh
you're not a vampire the sun won't fry
you now it's glorious
it's wondrous
it's burning my eyes
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever seriously
everybody relax just enjoy the view
ah please being a human is the worst
mosquito
hotel transylvania transfer mania boy
that was fun
the only place to experience transfer
mania is in a movie theater
october 1st
[Music]
when all hope seems lost
a dog actually sir i'm a puppy
that's even worse you're in shock so i'm
not gonna take that personally
this summer another perfect rescue the
worldwide phenomenon
will be unleashed on the big screen
paw patrol what's your emergency my name
is liberty we need your help
humdinger he's going to destroy
adventure city
come on pups adventure city's in trouble
[Music]
welcome to our new headquarters
is so cool there's even a new and
improved puff treat dispenser
what it's a beautiful thing
no dog by order of the new mayor he's
more of a cat person
ladies and gentlemen and most
importantly influencers with over 10 000
followers
[Music]
we've got to rescue those people let's
get to work i mean
paw patrol is on a roll are you
kidding me i got this get out of the way
move you got to know how to talk to
people
now go
[Music]
this is what we do no city's too big
no pups too small
the boy wedgie drone
yikes
you may not believe it but there is
magic all around us
there are times it can be hard to find
did you bring your garbage to school
but sometimes stuff the magic
finds us look at you number casey
so cute i'm so red how big is he gonna
get
that depends doesn't it unless on how
much you love him
i wish you were big and strong and the
world could nervous
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna be
bless you
[Music]
why don't we get you on the scale here
bud i'm just gonna write
heavy what if you found someone who made
you feel like you could do anything
[Music]
clicker no no oh no
no no donkey
[Music]
oh
well you don't see that every day maybe
it's time to feed him
thousands of years the bond between
my children and i was
perfect
now a dark presence threatens to destroy
the amazon
i'm above kendama greatest hunter in the
whole amazon
rainbow you are a very special person
you were called by the spirits hello
where are your spirit guys you have to
save the village
you need to be strong we have to stop
them
it is time for us to be brave
the jungle needs you no rainbow
you are the whole you just need to
believe in yourself
it's me and the jungle now but even the
greatest hunter can use a little help
[Music]
that's not a huge
are you ready this is the main event
he's coming
whoa
come get some of this
[Applause]
who wants a selfie tentacular
i've got your whole life story tattooed
on my body yeah
in a long history of monster wrestling
there has never been a champion quite
like centeka
fans around the world are asking is
there a challenger out there with the
hunger
the drive the discipline to become the
next
champion
what all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him
did he eat thank you
that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
what yeah that's gonna be a hard no for
me
[Music]
oh this is my nightmare
welcome king james
i'm a cartoon i'm shorter than kevin
hart
[Music]
what's up doc bring it here man
what brings you to tonwa doc the
computer dude kidnapped my son
what in the matrix hell
hey what'd you do to my son the only way
you getting your son back is if you and
i play a little basketball you want to
play me in basketball
i'll take it from here sam shoot the
ball
let's try that again shall we we'll get
your son back
i promise what's happening
i look expensive introducing
the goon squad
everything you love well at least we're
good
oh and i almost forgot all of the tunes
will be deleted so
come on guys the tune squad doesn't give
up if we're going out
we're going out looney
you gotta win this game and get our son
back
up the chance let's go twos i've got
hops
coming off the bench widely coyote
the machine's producing multiple riley
coyotes
[Applause]
well that happened wow
[Music]
we need a boost a secret weapon come on
man granny's out here having a martini
at halftime kate is gonna hate
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
welcome to the
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
everybody here for the interview
me too what do you drive i got the jet
bike
they're ready to see you mr crew oh good
great here we go
distinguished villains my name is cru
i feel like i'm talking too loud even
though
our proximity doesn't require this kind
of volume
you seriously think a puny little child
can be a villain yes i am pretty
despicable
you don't want to cross me
back when you've got something evil to
impress me
i'll distract them
i'll handle this
this is the biggest day of my life this
kid
just stole something from the world's
[Music]
now all i need is otto where is are you
pulling on my legs right now otto
where's the stone
oh vegas
[Music]
did you just trade my future
for a petra
oh i didn't mean to scare you now
where's groom
come on let's go we gotta catch up with
scooby doo
in the middle of nowhere
scooby-doo found a little courage that's
me
[Music]
it's my friends oh
and a lot of adventure
like man this place is totally freaky
why is the water dripping upward
now if you're in a situation i've never
seen cicadas that big before
more weird and creepy mysterious stuff
happens in nowhere than anywhere else in
the world
it's on our planet
enjoy
[Music]
and nowhere to hide
godzilla tight oh thank you
we got a safe scoop
straight out of nowhere scooby-doo meets
courage the cowardly dog
jackpot watch the masters at work
needs more mustard
excuse me must have been something i ate
look for it on digital and dvd
[Music]